our silver medal winner is yet a second
accolade for stanford university
made there by director anthony weeks his
film imaginary circumstances follows
three actors each with different
disabilities as they address the reality
of how hollywood tends to portray and
betray the truth when dealing with
people who are disabled
i'm still stunned i'm still stunned to
be here and
thrilled and honored and humbled and
grateful so um thank you first to the
academy for recognizing my film
and also
just for recognizing that uh this is an
issue that perhaps we could start
talking about a little bit more
i also want to give a special
congratulations to not only the other
filmmakers in the documentary category
but to all the filmmakers because this
week you've truly been an inspiration
and
i just i look forward to seeing more of
your work i look forward to
knowing you collaborating with you
perhaps
i'd like to
give a shout out to two of my alma
maters to stanford university to
the mfa program and documentary
specifically to jan krawitz chris
samuelson johnny simons and jamie
meltzer
also i did a little one-year program at
the new school and
deirdre boyle and annie howell were both
people who guided me and helped me a lot
i can't
i can't
thank my family enough because i think
that my family has been
supportive in everything that i've done
and my mom is here tonight and i'm
thrilled about that so thank you mom and
thanks to my family and thanks to olivia
for her inspiration
i'd also like to say thank you for to
support and friendship and love
and
finally i'd like to thank the three main
characters in the film because again in
terms of inspiration they have taught me
more in two years than i've learned in a
lifetime so
diana elizabeth jordan who's the main
character in the film is here tonight so
diana can you stand up please
and also i couldn't have made the film
without the support and encouragement
from robert david hall and from jerry
jewell
and from all the talented people at
performing arts studio west
finally i just have to say that
the most common refrain i've heard this
week when i've talked to people about
the film is
i've never thought of this before
and i think that
it's great because
now people are thinking of it and so the
film has done its job but
i guess it's my great hope that with
this film it will be a small
contribution to an ongoing conversation
that will transform this epiphany of i
haven't thought of this before into
meaningful complicated
representations of people with
disability on screen thank you